Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Jason from
Oahu?
Is that in Hawaii?
Speaker 2: Did an interview.
Speaker 1: OK, I can.
I think the tubes must be narrow coming in
from Hawaii because you sound a little bit
strange, but I'm curious how things are going
there.
Speaker 2: Yeah, things are great out here.
I just wanted to comment on your recent segment
on the right wing propaganda and the architecture
of it, please.
It was brilliant.
Thank you for the question, though.
So in regards to the specific topic, that
person I'm talking about, what do you think
the implications are?
Or do you think it's that farfetched to think
that there might be some kind of subversion
going on with the FBI?
We know that there were crowd noise.
And what was the Oath Keepers that were there?
What would be what would necessarily be the
bad thing that he was saying or what he was
implying with that segment?
Speaker 1: There's no evidence for it whatsoever.
So, as I said before, you know, some right
wingers now, they love to say,
Speaker 2: oh, by
Speaker 1: the way, are you brewing tea?
What is that
Speaker 2: noise?
I'm actually I'm I'm on my way to work.
OK, so I'm I'm I'm like, are you sure?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So so here's here's the deal.
A lot of right wingers now love to say, you
stupid liberals now all of you love the CIA,
you love the FBI.
You all think American intelligence agencies
can do no wrong because of their concern around
Trump and Russia and all of this different
stuff.
That's not the case whatsoever.
It's sort of like with the lab leak covid
stuff.
I'm not against investigating anything.
The problem is Tucker did a segment with no
evidence where he went in a three minute period
from these folks could be FBI agents to these
were FBI agents to the FBI, organized the
Trump riots, all without evidence.
So if anybody organized the riots, I want
to know about it.
But we can't just shift the narrative to this
is what happened without any actual evidence.
And so far, there's been no evidence presented
whatsoever.
We were aware of like an oath keeper dude
who was functioning as an FBI informant.
That's a very different thing than the FBI
planned, orchestrated and perpetrated the
Trump riots.
So what Tucker did wrong is that he presented
no evidence.
There's no evidence for what he's saying.
Speaker 2: Right, no, yeah, I think and again,
that was a brilliant way of pointing that
out and maybe showing your audience, including
myself, tools to recognize that, I guess I
don't know.
It just seems to me that it would have been
easy to kind of identify these things if the
Republicans had blocked the commission.
Speaker 1: So that's another point.
That's another point which is all of a sudden
now they're demanding investigations.
They blocked the investigation.
And you're completely right about that.
Speaker 2: Hey, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
My pleasure.
Would love to get to Hawaii someday.
Would love to get there